let's go through the teams of the NFC
East we did this yesterday with the AFC
East each one what do they have to get
in the draft let's start with the
Cowboys they cannot leave this draft
without a what Chris I think though the
position I look at more than anything
would probably be a safety it's a
position they've been trying to fill for
a long time now I don't know if that's
something they take in the first round
okay Mike I don't know you know I'm not
done evaluating safeties to know if
there's gonna be a guy there to be taken
for them in the first round but
nonetheless where they sit in the second
third I look at that as being you know
safety certainly Pat another pass rusher
which is very valued there but I think
safety more than anything with Jeff
Heath getting up there in age Xavier
wood Xavier woods is a good safety but I
think you know a guy that they probably
look at to go I don't know how long of a
career he could be as a starter here
yeah I think a safety position is one I
look at for the Dallas Cowboys that's a
true need for their football team you
know and I was gonna say corner because
Byron Jones left features and see for
the Dolphins you got to replace him but
that offensive line they spent so much
time they spent so many first-round
draft picks in an effort to turn that
offensive line into a powerhouse and now
you've got to a point where Tyron Smith
maybe not as dominant as he used to be
Travis Frederick retires maybe they just
need to get a new center I know Joe
loonies gonna take over they resided
Travis Frederick was a guy they believed
in he was a perennial Pro Bowler and
we've talked in the past how important
that position is on the offensive line
we've seen that offensive line go from
being the unquestioned best in the NFL
to yeah maybe it's in the upper half of
the pack now they need to get it back to
where it was if they want to get the
most out of the offense so I think they
need to come out of this with a great
offensive lineman ideally a replacement
for Travis Frederick
well well they're interesting to me out
of all the teams here in the NFC East
you know I think all the other three
teams that we'll talk about here in a
second have one truly glaring need you
know yeah this offseason and free agency
you know yeah they lost Robert Quinn
that was a huge loss to them on the edge
of their defense so that's where I'm
like I'm torn and then also you look at
go okay who's gonna be that third
receiver for the Dallas Cowboys this
year - you know so your corner thing is
not wrong I would you you know they have
some younger guys who have played in the
slot or maybe a little unproven on the
outside other than shidou be a loser
who's really really good so that's a
real thing you know yes your offensive
line thoughts not bad either pass rusher
I look at that so the Cowboys uh they do
have some true positional needs going
into this draft for a team that still
got a lot of talent there's a few holes
to be filled for sure yeah you know
that's a great point you don't think
about it much with the Cowboys because
we assume that they haven't had to do
much reloading or or retooling but they
do they really do we'll talk about dak
Prescott keeping Amari Cooper they
signed a Zico Elliott the big name
players are there but the guys who
become a key part of the foundation of
being successful those guys some of
those guys are gone and they're gonna
have to replace them alright the Eagles
cannot leave the 2020 draft without what
Chris well this is easy it's wide
receiver and they have to get a wide
receiver I mean Nelson Aguilar is gone
al Sean Jeffries getting up there in age
he was hurt last year DeSean Jackson yes
he could still run but he's getting up
there in age and was hurt last year so
you know one they need some talent at
the position - they need a guy you know
for depth of the position and they can't
count on out so Jeffrey in - Sean
Jackson at this age of the career to
play a 16 you know 16 full 16 game full
season I think that's a very real thing
and we you know again we talked about
this last week and at the combine how
heroes been taught told us one of the
big things in this offseason was going
to be the ability to support Carson
Wentz with some weapons around him
they've yet to really do that so I would
think during the draft you know running
backs wide receivers are gonna be a part
of their game plan for sure but wide
receiver especially they need to find a
go-to young receiver for Carson Wentz in
that Eagles offense and all I'll add to
that is it's got to be a fast receiver
it's got to be somebody who can take the
top off the defense stretch the defense
out and open up everything underneath
DeSean Jackson was that guy really for
one game last year
and it was a huge impact they were down
double digits to Washington week one and
all of a sudden Carson once told me this
after the game they hit wanted to Sean
Jackson it changed everything you need
that guy who can be the home run threat
and I don't think you can count on
DeSean Jackson being right if he is this
year great but you need somebody else
who becomes that guy down the road much
like the way they found to Sean Jackson
all those years ago Giants can't leave
the draft without what Chris offensive
tackle I mean another that's an easy it
slam dunk I mean then you know now not
again I don't know if they got to take
him at number four they might be able to
take him in the second round but you
know I look at the New York Giants and
go alright Nate's older just like we
talked about with the Eagles yeah he's
still a good player but he's not great
he's getting up there in age you got to
start thinking about replacing him they
got some journeyman at right tackle and
some unproven commodities there so to me
that is the no brainer I would think
with one of the first two picks the
Giants have in the draft they are going
to go offensive tackle I would think
that is and the Giants at number four
Mike you know they might not look at any
offensive tackle being worthy of the
number four pick I don't know they would
be an ultimate trade down team I would
look at right now to think oh if
somebody's interested in quarterbacks or
the way their teams built they could
certainly trade down if they got a bunch
of offensive tackle is very closely
graded yeah what's the day of get them a
term the hog mollies they need some hot
mollies they need and they need them on
both sides of the line they need to get
back to the point where they have a
great defensive line and a great
offensive line that all due respect to
Eli Manning
they won those Super Bowls in 2007 2011
because they had great offensive line
great defensive line continuity on the
offensive side of the ball and
disruption on the defensive side of the
ball that's it they need to get back to
so I agree with you there all right with
the Giants if you want say Kwan Berkeley
and Daniel Jones your two top six picks
or the last two drafts to be really
successful you better help them you know
get some holes and pass protection so
you want to protect those investments
sorry go ahead
absolutely Washington cannot leave the
draft without what Chris they're like
the Philadelphia Eagles the wide
receiver position there's just not
enough there you know and again not that
they have to
you know take a firt you don't have to
drop the first round wide receiver as we
saw Terry Maclaurin last year was what a
third or a fourth round pick for the
Washington Redskins he's a superstar but
nonetheless if you want the Dwayne
Haskins experiment and era to get off on
the right foot you got to put some more
weapons around him you know again
there's not really really talented tight
ends on the roster at this point running
backs is a big question mark so there's
holes to be filled there you know it's
Adrian Peterson and he's up there and
age but wide receiver other than Terry
Maclaurin tell me somebody you're even
slightly concerned about really is a
dangerous aspect on that reskin Redskins
offense so that would be the first one I
would look at if I'm a Redskins uh front
office man I agree with you there and if
you want to get the most out of Dewayne
Haskins you had to give him some
protection they need to resolve the
trent williams situation once and for
all get what they can for him and get
another left tackle start that process
over reset at that position quit being
stubborn about trent williams move on
from him and find somebody else
otherwise it doesn't matter who you have
it receiver if your quarterback is
running for his life all day long Chris
yeah no it does not you're exactly right
so you know you look at the Redskins
there's a lot of positive things there
their defensive line legit they got some
people there they might have a chance
you know of course they're sitting there
right now where you gonna go they're
gonna have chase young with Montes sweat
who they drafted in the first round last
year and then the two alabama boys in
the middle who are both first-round
picks I mean holy crap that'll be some
defensive line it'll be one of the more
talented ones in all of football but
yeah the Redskins they need to find some
weapons on the offensive side the side
of the ball and become more of an
explosive offense and one thing that
benefits Washington they have a new
coach in Ron Rivera who has been there
and done that with no offseason program
his first year with the Panthers there
was nothing until training camps so he
and not not that they were great right
away but they laid the foundation for
greatness and he may be in a great
position to help them get the most out
of whoever they find in the dress
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports